[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sept ans j'ai commencé à faire je
l'utilisé comme netflix
c'est qui c'est quoi même soir d'être
regardé ce que je n'ai pas ça je suis
content mais c'est à dire que je suis de
succès
mm à 10h30 du matin à sentir bien à
faire attention
fouler cette panique
parce que subitement plus c'est un texte
plus une chose évidente plus des mots
évident en plus des termes simples 7 a
fait appel l'acajou conditions de 500
pour moi je suis intimement persuadé
c'est une erreur
c'est un suicide chaque fois le
spectacle la concertation
et tous total à une fin de ce politique
intervient 10 du capital
oui mais sont maintenant partis mi mars
la fête est terminée tout n'est pas ce
qu'on peut lire et nous a condamné la
551e présentation
[Musique]